welcome back to the road to 2000 as
always my name is Caleb and I will be
your driver for tonight's lesson so what
I talked about last week was in kind of
an introduction to closed structures in
chess and what I went through that week
was basically the the Kings Indian
structure so that's with white pawns on
you know D 5 e 4 and C 4 and black pawns
on you know c7 d65 those kind of
structures and so today I want to kind
of relate them to a different type of
closed structure that shows up quite
often in chess and that's the you know
kind of advanced French or advanced
caro-kann pawn structure so what that
means is basically what you see right
here on the board white has these pawns
on d4 and d5 and black has these pawns
on e6 and d5 and that's kind of the the
core of the structure the center is
closed because these two pawns are these
four pawns rather don't really move
around all that often and so based on
what we learned last week you know the
principles of play on the side where you
have more space so for white that would
be the Kings side and for black that
would be you know the Queen side what do
you think the plans are what are the
pawn breaks going to be for both sides
so yeah where does where does white play
I already told you the Kings side right
so what type of moves is white going to
be playing what type of pawn breaks with
these three pawns yeah so very often f5
is going to be a pawn break usually you
start with something like g4 and what
pawn breaks is black going to be playing
yeah so c5 you know attack this this
backward pawn on d4 not a backwards pawn
but the base of the pawn chain and then
something I want to touch on a little
bit later in today's lecture is a
different sort of idea of playing these
positions so you know the the classical
way that I was talking about last time
which works you know almost all the time
in the Kings Indian is to attack the
base of the pawn chain on the side where
you have more space but you know and
specifically the French jarash black
actually picks a different approach to
attacking this type of pawn chain so
what happens in the French tirage or
what is the other idea for black in this
kind of structure any idea yes so you
can actually attack this ahead of the
pawn chain but very often this turns out
to be a lot a lot more dangerous you
know because it kind of you're playing
on the side where you have less space
right so you can run into you know
certain attacks certain tactics and it's
very easy to go wrong which is why you
know when it is played it's usually
played only in very specific
circumstances it's far more common to
see the c5 idea and black looking for
counter play on the Queen side so right
now this doesn't look like a care
structure because they're pawns on c7
but just to show how we could transpose
something like you know c5 eventually
gets played in both openings very often
C 3 C takes D C takes D and this is kind
of a natural continuation of the pawn
structure and still black is going to be
looking for play on this Queen side
maybe on this C file and you know maybe
with these two pawns as well gaining
some more space with a 6 and b5 and
sometimes B 4 as well with that being
said let's jump into the first game here
so in this game I had black and I was
instead 1900 and this game happened
actually quite recently I believe it was
at a I I think I played this at Pan Am's
I'm actually kind of misremembering now
but we can see the game started with E
for I play the Carol con c6 d 4 D 5 and
E 5 yeah it was a classical time control
this was yeah wherever it was played all
I know is it was definitely classical
and so we we've almost achieved the
structure we just looked at right so the
structure would happen after something
like e six but black isn't going to want
to play this right away
do you know why no well actually the
idea of the caro-kann as opposed to the
French because the structure could be
reached via this move order this would
be the advanced French which we might
take a look at the idea with delaying
this is you can develop this Bishop it's
very often in the French you know the
bishop gets stuck behind the pawns so
we're gonna develop the Bishop to f5
Black has one other option there but
we're gonna focus on this for today so
now that the bishop is developed you
know this Bishop can be a strength
because it's you know more active but it
can also kind of be a detriment to
Black's position and what do you think
the reason for that might be after
something like I don't know Knight f3
okay let's say Knight c3 and ecigs
what's an interesting idea for white
here that you guys might have seen
before and I've actually tell a lecture
on this opening line before yeah it's
it's the shear of attack and so uh white
tries to say okay you've developed this
Bishop but I can actually make it work
in my favor so what did we just say that
White's plan often is in these
structures what is yeah attack on the
Kings side and what pawn break is white
trying to play for
yeah White would like to play this f4 f5
pawn break so because of that very often
well not as often because it is risky to
move your pawns this thus far in the
opening we sometimes see this g4 move
and then uh usually not in this position
but later on white tries to play f4 f5
and gain you know more than one tempo on
this Bishop actually so we'll see this
idea of the bishop getting kicked around
and in later games maybe but in this
game my opponent actually played a
pretty weak line against the Carroll he
actually just played Bishop to d3 and so
because sometimes this Bishop becomes
awkward I'm gonna say that this is kind
of the first inaccuracy of the game you
know white kind of misunderstands that
okay this bishops outside the pawn chain
but it advances my plan in a lot of
cases so I shouldn't you know do
anything about it just yet whereas here
you're trading off you know maybe
White's good bishop and you're just
getting rid of this this hook that you
have to attack you know to advance your
plans so I'd say this is a pretty
significant mistake actually so I
captured the bishop he captured with the
Queen and I went ahead and played e6 we
see f4 right away this move is also a
bit strange it's a nice idea to try to
get this pawn break through right away
but it is also coming with you know some
disadvantages as well why might white
not want to play f4 right away any ideas
well yeah he's under develops but it's
not as though I'm going to you know
launch some attack on his King right you
know that's usually the problem when
you're underdeveloped is you know your
King gets attacked or some weakness gets
attacked right away and you can't really
defend whereas that's not really gonna
happen here because if you notice I'm
not exactly ahead in development right
so there are other problems with that
for besides you know delaying
development
yeah one thing is it kind of blocks in
this bishop and very not very often in
this opening does the bishop come all
the way out here or to f4 but it'd be
nice to have this diagonal open for the
bishop still and there's one last thing
that I want to mention about f4 yeah yes
so I mean it does block off this so the
knight in theory can go to h6 yeah so
then I can come to h6 which is just an
under another route it can take to get
to f5 which is an important square so
those are all good points but so the
last thing I want to mention is it
actually weakens White's King right so
what do I mean when I say that I don't
mean that right away I have Queen h4
check and after g3 in Queen g4 I'm
launching an attack on white because I
just don't have the pieces developed to
back that up right so this would all be
nonsense
but we'll see as the game goes on how
this f4 move kind of comes back to to
haunt white because it really does
weaken a lot of squares around the white
King no matter where the white King
decides to go if he tries to castle
later on this diagonal is going to be a
lot weaker no the pawns on f4 and later
on in the game this is kind of this is
also actually a common thing that
happens is f4 really weakens the
second-ranked right you have this pawn
on f4 on f2 and it helps defend your
king right you can play things like g3
and King g2 later on and you have this
f2 pawn for shelter from any pieces on
the second-ranked but with the pawn on
f4 none of that really exists and the
white King actually runs into a lot of
trouble a lot of times in a lot of
different end games so for all of those
reasons f4 is an actually a great move
it's trying to you know it's got the
right heart behind it it's trying to
follow through with this pawn break but
you do have to pay attention and notice
when you play things that you know
weaken your King side like this so what
do you think well I'll just play the
move I played Queen b6 I think this has
actually never been played before but
it's kind of a simple idea I'm just
putting pressure here and I'm putting
pressure here so it might be difficult
for white to get developed we see c3
played defending his D pawn I went ahead
and played c5 Knight f3 I just thought
it might be white might have this extra
option because now I'm not attacking b2
but probably white wouldn't want to go
in for something like this anyways if I
had to guess he'd much rather have I
think a pawn on d4 I might be wrong on
this cuz there are a lot of situations
when white takes on d4 with the bishop
but if there is a meaningful difference
I'd say this is this is kind of it I
didn't have to think about any of this
because I played Queen b6 first so a
queen b6 c3 c5 Knight f3 I captured here
he captured with the pawn I went ahead
and played a knight c6 a3 was played
this move is actually just aimed at
preventing stuff like night before from
you know kind of invading White's camp
bullies underdeveloped on the Queen side
I went ahead and continued it continued
developing using this idea of Knight h6
Knight to c3 was played also developing
the pieces Knight to f5 the pawn was
attacked so white decided to defend it
with Knight to e2 and now what move do
you think black should play here this
one's rather important
well what is what would like what would
white like to do yeah
white would like to you know see maybe
okay so I played which should be seven
but h5 was also the other idea that I
wanted to talk about because if you do
nothing if you play like a six White's
gonna try to roll over you with this
this g4 and f5 pawn break right so black
has to do something about this so in the
game I played this move Bishop e7 and so
now what would the idea be after a g4
yeah I would have this interesting move
Knight h4 and the point is you know
white doesn't really have time to play
something like f5 here because I can
take this night and take this pawn and
if white doesn't play f5 right away if
he does something like castles will say
so this stops the threat by allowing him
to defend here then I have another
interesting move here and what should
black play otherwise blacks gonna be in
a bit of trouble like has to do
something kind of immediate
certainly not f5 at five weekends to too
many things if we play f5 right away
he's gonna take on pissant probably we
might take with the bishop and I this
qualifies is interesting because you're
trying to pile up here but you've
weakened all of all of these squares
right and that's gonna come back to
haunt you maybe after I will say Knight
h4 bishop h4 even g5 here and this
bishops getting kind of kind of tripped
and this pawn is gonna be weakness it's
not my favorite thing
what else can black try aimed at
preventing this fi break from smashing
through
yeah g6 does try to prevent it one
problem is it's kind of stranding this
night for a long time I mean you can you
can trade nights before anything else
but that doesn't really solve your
problems right and just delays it for a
move yeah h5 and this presents white
with actually quite a few problems black
hasn't cancelled yet so you would
actually love to open this age file and
a huge positional blunder for a white
would be would be to play this this g5
move so why would it be a huge
positional blunder it shouldn't be too
difficult to tell exactly right I don't
know if Knight f5 right away it works
cuz maybe white has some interesting
pawn sacrifice I feel like this should
be nothing for white though enough white
doesn't try something like that
something like a few plays like b4 I'll
just play g6 next turn and then there's
absolutely nothing white can do to
achieve a meaningful pawn break and so
that that means there's no way for him
to open up the position and no way for
him to use his extra space and black
will simply have easy play on the Queen
side so maybe white can try something
like h3 and then after takes takes but
so like I said blacks happy to have this
this open file for his rook and I think
this shouldn't be too dangerous I'm
trying to think what we might see after
this any ideas yeah castling Queen Queen
side is isn't yeah you're right but it's
not the most natural thing to do but it
makes a lot of sense here actually you
can also probably play g6 here as well
maybe after throwing in takes on a takes
on f3 this is something like this this
g6 with the idea of you know getting
getting play on the on the Kings side
actually well this kind of goes against
the idea you know White has more space
on the Kings side but here actually
White has also made a lot of weaknesses
on the kings
right and I'm also kind of now noticing
a huge problem with f5 for white and the
line I specified which is this pawn
would hang due to a pin yeah yeah that's
a good point but like all of these all
these ideas make just as much sense if
if white doesn't castle under this pin
and plays something like I'm not sure
what else would white would play yeah
rook f1 maybe actually Bishop e3 after
takes but yeah I don't know what giving
up this B pawn is an idea so I'm trying
to find some clever way to defend my
pawn here but maybe you were kept one is
actually just the the best way to do it
but regardless the point of all this was
you know you always have to have some
idea against this g4 f5 pawn break as
black which here it's a bit more
complicated than the other move which is
simply h5 that was suggested to stop g4
but you know it also it's just important
that you have an idea to prevent white
from just rolling over your position
right away
so we saw Bishop e7 castles perhaps now
what the idea of playing g4 so here I
went ahead and played age 5 and now what
who do you think is better here if
anybody
yeah that's that's what I would say it's
not a huge advantage right because you
know you know black hasn't won any
material black hasn't created any
devastating weaknesses that White's
gonna have to deal with but whites
actually just caused a lot of annoying
problems for himself right he's put this
pawn on f4 which is kind of weakening
this diagonal it's kind of weakening
this rank it's kind of weakening this
King he's left himself with his
backwards b2 pawn which maybe he'll push
it to b4 but maybe that actually creates
other weaknesses he has this awkward
pawn on on d4 that he's always having to
babysit and he has no real plan that's
the huge thing he has no plan to
activate his pieces and because of that
I'd much rather play black here
I wouldn't say black is winning yet
because you know black like I said
hasn't won anything material-wise and
he's not really making any huge threats
but it's just much easier to move blacks
pieces around so with that said we said
you know black does have a clear plan so
what would that be from blacks point of
view how does white how does black
actually advance we might start by okay
you know we might start by completing
development here but I'll ask you from
this position
yeah that's exactly right you simply
want to improve your pieces we mentioned
earlier when we were talking about just
the pawn structure that the big pond
break was c5 and then taking on d4
usually which since Black has already
achieved that he simply wants to
activate his pieces so in my opinion the
best way to do that is to like I like
you mentioned put rooks on the C file
and try to improve this Knight somehow
by maybe coming to see for maybe eying
b3 and just go from there so let's see
what happened in the game so I'm trying
to turn up the brightness here in the
game I went ahead and played direct c8
as you mentioned it might be more
natural to go with this rook but in my
head I was thinking maybe the circ is
going to be useful here somehow because
there's some ideas of playing f6 and
some positions I don't know how true
that is but that's what I was thinking
at the time and I also thought maybe if
white ever does get these these pawn
breaks and I'd like to have a reckon the
F file looking back I think it makes
just as much sense to come with the
other rook maybe more sense but I don't
know I don't think it's a huge
difference so Rick I c8 Knight g3 so
this is something I see a lot of players
fall back on which is they can't find a
clear plan so what they do instead is
just start trading pieces for the sake
of trading pieces and instead of this
what do you think whites should have
done to try to you know save this game
he can't find a clear plan on the Kings
side but he can do something else
yeah so that's exactly right so a lot of
times in chess it's not so easy to find
a good way to advance your plan and when
that's the case and sometimes even when
you do have a clear way to advance the
best thing to do is actually prevent
your opponent's ideas so my ideas are to
just you know double up on this C file
and improve my night right so because of
that you can look at moves like rook F
to c1 for white you know and this is
kind of giving up on this this f4 f5
idea but this is actually one of the
best ways for white to try to defense in
my opinion the move that was mentioned
was B for which this is another good
idea but this is a highly committal move
now why would I why would I say that
yeah it's it's allowing a future pawn
break maybe this pawn break isn't yeah
maybe this pawn break isn't great right
now because why it has this b5 move but
later on down the line this is always
gonna be something you have to worry
about so I would definitely you know
consider these moves like rook to c1 and
b4 I think this is the best way for
white to continue here
it's simply accepting okay I don't have
any advantage there's no way for me to
break through on the Kings side right
now
maybe I'll just you know switch to the
Queen side and try to try to hold off
you know on my opponents plan we see
Knight e3 instead which really like I
said it's kind of just trading pieces
for the sake of trading pieces I went
ahead and captured because I don't want
to let him ruin my pawn structure he
takes with the bishop and now I play g6
again it's important to always make sure
that your opponent's pawn breaks aren't
you know going to come through and now
we see finally this b4 move that was
mentioned so he was worried about Knight
to a5 to c4 so we chose to stop it with
with b4 which makes sense to me I go
ahead and play York c7 he plays York to
d1 I play rook to F to c8 and now it's
kind of the only moment in the game my
opponent had a chance to try to fight
back so what was I maybe
not giving enough credit by just simply
doubling on this e-file
yeah that's right
so this f5 pawn break anyways can
actually be very problematic for me here
yes so the point is how would black like
to take this pawn back would you rather
play G takes effort e takes F in a
perfect world so he'd rather play you
know e takes F but now after six
I've actually trapped my own rope by
playing her to c8 and so there's nothing
I can really do about this here so this
would force me to play G takes f and
then a white actually has quite a lot of
counter play here that I didn't really
account for in the game I'm not entirely
sure how the line might start but this
was kind of the point of putting this
rook on d1 is it gives these pieces a
little bit more freedom to move around
yes you might start with Queen e3 you
might start with Bishop h4 but either
way you know white can actually start
mounting an attack here let's say a
Bishop h4 and already I'm not sure what
I what I want to do with my with my
pieces here that doesn't quite work
right so if takes takes and takes on e5
unfortunately there's this fork so yeah
so maybe actually just something like
what am I am I missing something right
right yeah so yeah I think something
like you know King age 7 or King h8
would make the most sense for me just to
try to reorganize my pieces maybe it's
really tough to decide between these two
squares let's say takes and then h7 so
I'm not allowing 95 and already you can
kind of see maybe rack f3 isn't great
right away maybe there's like net of 5
ideas but white I was quite a bit of
counter play here and this was kind of
my opponents only chance to try to break
through like this so because of that
what do you think a better move would be
here yeah so that's when I do it
actually is you can try to play
something like Bishop to d8 it looks a
little awkward one reordering of the
pieces that I might have considered as
rook to e8 here and so now the point is
uh if you play something like this we
can maybe drop back to f8 and now you
know I'm not sure how we might continue
something like this and well now that
the bishop isn't on g3 anymore I might
go ahead and play here see something
like g4 takes takes and 97 so we're
stopping this and we're getting our
pieces in this is kind of one way I
might have reordered the pieces which
it's kind of clunky and kind of slow but
unfortunately our opponent has wasted so
much time that we are kind of breaking
through first here which you can kind of
see so yeah his idea with rook do you
want is it actually kind of makes some
sense and some of these lines now
especially after work to c8 it gives
this piece freedom to move it adds
another defender to d4 which is kind of
what allowed those bishop h4 Knight h4
ideas yeah which I I don't know if they
actually saw that in the game though
because he didn't play a fight here but
he kind of wanted to give his pieces
more mobile more mobility as what I
would say instead of that we saw a
bishop h4 and after Bishop takes h4 and
I takes h4 I simply played 97
and now there's really no way for for
wait to get this f5 breakthrough anymore
cuz my nights here it's defending this
f5 square and you know like I said
anything white tries is going to be way
too slow because I'm already breaking
through on the C file so now I think
it's already to wait for too late for
white I don't think there's any way for
him to really save this position and now
you can really see the why white would
have liked to be on the C file because
with my rich is completely dominating
uncontested there's really no chance for
white to get back into this game and the
game we saw him try Rick to f3 maybe
he's trying to play with g3 with some
you know sacrificial ideas I simply
played a 5 now I decided was the
appropriate moment for this breakthrough
like I said before was committal it
always gives black these options of
playing this a 5 move and trying to
break it down this ran into b5 when now
I simply play Rick to c1 I had a couple
options here York to c4 would have been
a good move for it to c2 would have been
a fine move even Newark to c3 probably
working theory is bad actually
because white would just take it but you
know plenty of options rook c1 was what
I chose threatening to capture and then
capture because of this white plays well
white just place work to g3 I guess
hoping that you know his counter play on
the Kings side is enough but obviously
you know it it's just way too slow I
take on d1 he took some d1 I take on b5
he plays h3 here hoping to give his King
some shelter but like I said now this
this f4 pawn actually comes into play
because without this pawn enough to his
king is still going to be far too weak
even if it hides on the h2 square and we
see that coming to play pretty soon so I
just bring my pieces in closer Queen B 2
is very natural something he might have
tried here I guess is rook to b3 how
would I have had to respond to this yeah
something like exceed one would probably
be just winning a winning in game 4
black takes too
and takes here takes here maybe maybe
not Knight f5 I probably don't want to
trade those maybe I can get away with
taking this with check I'm gonna say I
can get away with taking this with check
and after King g3 I'll play a miss g5
move and yeah I mean you can take I can
take and it's it's just two extra pawns
for black so yeah rook b3 would have
traded undo this losing end game which
was maybe a try for white instead we see
a king h2 trying is to keep the game
going
I simply player it to c1 you know
bringing in my pieces on the set I have
more space on this side my pieces have
more options and my opponent has more
weaknesses which is why black is winning
this game so we see Queen to a4 uh yeah
that's that's a good question actually I
forgot to mention that
so yeah queen h5 is is legal but it runs
into some serious problems what would
black play here maybe
Queen b1 wasn't at the top of my list
but it might be good enough might be
maybe best actually the move I was
thinking of was simply Queen to d4 with
the same idea you just threatened a
checkmate the most natural move is
Knight to f3 - stop it and now Queen to
f4 and the circus pinned this Queen is
actually trapped and yeah there's really
nothing for a for a white to do here
besides Queen g4 and let's see maybe
best is okay sure you can he can go to
g5 oh yeah that's a good point yeah
maybe I'll just take and yeah the Sun
gun would also be winning it feels like
black should have better maybe you're
right but this queen bee one move
actually defending this threatening this
and I don't think there's actually a way
for a white to get white to break
through he has to spend to move saving
his Queen and he also has to spend to
move stopping checkmate and you really
can't do both so yeah that's why Queen
h5 isn't good so we see Quinn i-4
instead trying to get into e8 black has
a few options here I actually just chose
Knight to c6 and now we actually saw
tonight takes g6 white decided okay I
have to do something here and
unfortunately forum Knight g6 isn't
working at all but you know it was in
attempts I captured he captured I attack
his rook he takes my pawn and now I had
a very interesting choice that I don't
get very often in my games I had to
choose between winning his queen or
checkmating his King which it's a
pleasant choice to have but what are
kind of you know the main two options
for black here what do you think
yeah so b5 is actually just you know
checkmate on the Queen but a checkmate
on the King is a little bit less
straightforward yeah you would play b5
this going all the way back to the first
road to 2000 class using this idea that
I've that I showed in a mating that
puzzle yeah
h4 is exactly right that's what I played
in the game no I play Queen f2 in the
game and then I played h4 but yeah I
don't know h4 immediately is probably
just fine might be even better but yeah
I don't know I played Queen f2 first I'm
sure it's fine queen of 2 actually comes
with the threat of checkmate which is
why you played York f6 and now I played
h4 again with the threat of checkmate
and the king is just stuck here there's
nothing I can do you checked me I moved
and the new your designs there's simply
no way to stop both of these threats so
yeah it kind of all went wrong very
quickly for white you know at one second
it seemed like okay maybe white doesn't
have a plan but you know it's not like
he's losing and then the next second you
know black was completely breaking
through on the Queen side so it's
important to be cautious when you don't
have a plan in situations like this
because you really do have to pay very
close attention and the key moment I
really do think is way back here on this
night g3 move right white should have
realized okay I mean this move doesn't
advance my plan all it does is trade off
a piece maybe it's trading off an
inactive piece for an active one and
that's you know a positive benefit for
me but so much better would be to simply
play something like b4 and you know
challenge challenge this file in my
opinion but even after this it's not too
late the key moment number two I think
is this Rick do one move when you really
have to play something like Rick to c1
you can even bring the area to c1 but I
think the effort makes more sense
and this would just be you know a lot
better way for white to try to contest
this game is to play or to see one so
this game is gonna be Igor blech
against Thomas Luthor which you know
it's a twenty five fifty playing at
twenty four sixty so you know a kind of
a low-level grandmaster game low-level
but uh let's see how things went wrong
for for black in this game and the key
differences we might find the last game
white kind of play you you know kind of
aimlessly right he made some weaknesses
and then he found all of a sudden I
can't get my plan through what do I do
I'll just trade pieces so here white
plays you know very clearly with very
distinct ideas which is the real
difference in a you know chess strategy
so e46 we see the same opening night of
three this should be to note that this
player chose to keep the bishops on the
board giving him these ideas of you know
g4 with tempo c5 attacking the pawn
white actually has a few options here
the main variation is opening now
actually goes with Bishop e3 which you
know black also has a couple options the
line I play is takes takes ninety seven
and this is actually a huge difference
in structure though this is no longer a
closed center opening this might be
something you call a semi open center or
a you know a fluid Center is something
I've heard and so because of that the
plans are gonna be completely different
here which is why I don't want to talk
too much about this I just want to you
know briefly mention that these openings
can you know go in a couple different
directions so here the plans are gonna
be totally different because the center
can open up so why it's gonna be playing
things like c4 eventually he's gonna try
to be attacking the white king right
away making you so this square possibly
and things are just gonna be totally
different but the line that white chose
in this game goes with castles and a c6
and c3 maintaining the closed centre
structure so we see takes takes 97 83
Bishop e4 90-93 Bishop takes f3 Bishop
takes f3 so black tried to get you know
this awkward Bishop out of the way early
on it's kind of not the most common idea
in this specific line but it's certainly
been played before we seen i-25 so why
it's putting pressure on this deep on
you know just trying to develop his
pieces and get counterplay where he has
more space we see Bishop III Bishop e7
and now white makes a very very
interesting move what are some ideas you
can think of for white here obviously in
general we still have this long term
plan of trying to get this F pawn
through with this Jeep on but uh it's
looking like that might not be so easy
to achieve right away
so one way to go about thinking about
this is to think okay what's the big
problem right now why can't I just play
something like g4 what's the issue maybe
not so much 9 takes t3 being an issue
but not h4 is a huge issue right it you
know it's attacking your bishop your
bishop has to move again and now there's
always this h5 idea that that can be
annoying right so because of that white
decided so what can I do to remove this
Knight and start pushing my pawns so now
that you've gone through this line of
thinking what's my plan all right why
can't I achieve my plan what can I do to
achieve it you want to remove the night
so how can you get rid of this night
well okay but how does this translate to
specific moves how can you take this
night how can you remove this night from
its square exactly right Bishop g4 white
plays very simply here he says okay I
want to move this F pawn to f5 I want to
you know play g4 this Knight is in my
way so I'm going to attack it and you
know black certainly doesn't want to
allow this change of structure this just
creates a lot of weaknesses for black
you know this age 7 pawn is weak you
know this F sub 1 is also weak now as
well as well as all of these dark
squares so this kind of forces black to
go for this change of structure within I
take C 3 and F take C 3 and already
white has kind of achieved his pawn
break in a sense right he didn't get to
play f5 but he did get to open up the
position which is the whole goal of the
pawn break he's opened up the position
for his pieces where he has more space
so let's say the game continued
continued with castles work I have two
white prepares you know maybe a couple
different ways of doubling on the F file
it also just protects this weak pawn oh
we see Bishop age 4 so this provokes
white to play a and g3 I'm not so sure
that this is a great move from black but
it makes some sense Bishop g5 attacking
may be a weakness but again I think it
would make a lot more sense for black to
just be playing instead of all this to
start going for these ideas on the
inside with you know moving this Queen
playing a6 b5 maybe putting a ruck on
the C file I think this would have made
more sense for black and said he goes in
for this kind of strange-looking
bishop maneuver white develops his queen
you know always eying the side where he
has more space always eyeing you know
opening up the position further where he
has more space we see Queen b6 mm-hmm
simply King to g2 just improves the king
queen a6 so uh black was actually just
kind of afraid of the King side attack
so he plays this kind of weird line to
try to trade off these queens something
we might have seen instead instead of
Queen b6 is a Miss a6 move this might
have been more in line with thinking
okay I don't care about the Kings side
I'm gonna play in the Queen side but
already since he's wasted some time with
this Bishop and you know allowed this F
file to open up he's gonna run into some
trouble with the Queen's on the board so
something might just happen like you
know Ricky 1b 5h4
and maybe uh as soon as this Knight
leaves the d4 square white opens it up
further and you really don't want the
Queen's on the board for positions like
this cuz you know blacks queen isn't
doing anything and whites queen is doing
quite a lot so maybe because of ones
like these blacks decided all right I'm
just gonna bite the bullet and spend two
moves to trade the Queen's
so we see Queen a six-way Cozad intakes
cuz it you know hurts black structure
takes takes rook to e1 supporting this
week pawn Knight a5 and I'm gonna say
this is a mistake so why it is night I 5
maybe not the best move because it's
kind of following these plans we talked
about right it's trying to improve his
piece but so it's leaving something
behind that's actually very important
and it all has to do with preventing
White's plan and furthering your own
plan
yes so that's exactly right you can even
start with h4 if you want but the main
idea I want to look at is this e for
move right white would like to play e4
so we can get his Knight into you know
better squares and so that's actually
why this Knight move is a mistake
so this knight on c6 it's a bit harder
to play e4 right if like like something
useful like rook to b8 then e for isn't
coming right away because this pawn is
hanging so yeah I would have liked to
see York to b8 from black I think this
would have been a much better line but
now like you said white can actually
just continue to gain more space so I
think white maintains an edge was
something like this but yeah instead
Knight a5 and white connection just
break through right away so we've seen
it to c4 instead you know as a response
white goes then takes on d5 black tries
to regain the pawn with this check King
h3 and ticks and now what do you think
white did you know he kind of opened
things up for himself but you shouldn't
be afraid to trade one advantage for
another so he did something kind of you
know not quite in line with the plan but
certainly giving himself a decent edge
for the game yeah why do you want to
take the knight
okay so that's one idea is pushing the
EEP on there but the other main idea
that I wanted to show is you know
saddles black with the weakness right
yeah so you take the knight and the
point is this pawn is gonna be weak
forever you have a light squared bishop
he's a dark squared Bishop so it's very
easy to attack this pawn you're getting
on the C file first as well and it's
going to be very difficult for black to
hold this all together so this is what
we saw in the game Bishop f3 attacking
this pawn to d8 and now White's on the C
file White's attacking the weaknesses
it's very very pleasant York to see it
so black actually gives up this d5 pawn
right away rather than what the rook in
so takes takes takes black tries this
move rip to d8 trying to regain the pawn
we see Bishop a2 takes rook F 1 so black
gets this pawn back but unfortunately
he's he's not gonna keep it for very
long because f7 is also a weak thanks to
the open F file it all comes back to you
know opening it up where you have more
space we see h6 rook f7 then I'll play
through this rather quickly because uh
blacks just losing here plays riff d2
white goes out and pushes with e6 and
now just technically white wins via this
e 7 move and what's the idea do you
think why doesn't black just play Bishop
e7 and take the pawn for free so yeah so
why does this move work tactically
because at first glance it looks like
you know Bishop takes e7 York takes t7
or takes c4 is okay for black right
route takes c4 but you know why it might
have some idea here
so how would you meet bishop take c7
just as a little tactical finish
yeah Bishop e6 is the move so the
problem right now with taking is it's
discovered a tech it's a check but you
know black can take so the idea is you
want to make it when you take this
bishop your Bishop is defended which is
how you come to this Bishop e6 move now
you know if route to c7 this check works
black has to get out of check before
recapturing so he loses and if he tries
to tack the bishop again now Ricky 7 is
actually defending our piece yeah King
f8 doesn't quite work because we can
come back to f7 in Africa 8 here we can
come to c4 I think and will untangle our
pieces so yeah that's how the game ended
actually black took here white played
Bishop e6 and then black resigned so I
went through that game a lot more
quickly but so any questions about how
black ended up worse and then how black
ended up losing no I kinda want to go
back to one or two key moments so I
think you know this Bishop age for
Bishop g5 stuff
I think this didn't really help blacks
plan at all so I think these were kind
of wasted Tempe and then second of all
this Knight a5 move really isn't helping
him at all you should have realized you
know this efore move is a very serious
idea this is what white once in the
position so we should have done as much
as you can to stop it and we work to be
8 I think puts up a lot more resistance
because it's not so easy to push eight
for this week deep on and now I think
white actually has to switch ideas and
start you know playing over here with
moves like Bishop f3 and g4 g5 and yeah
so I think you know this is where black
really started going wrong is you know
playing playing around with his bishop
on the Kings side when you know there's
really no ideas there and then not
noticing that
needs to stop efore whereas if you look
at the white pieces every move he played
had a very clear purpose right you know
all the way going back to this Bishop g4
move it's saying okay take on e3 and
open up the position or else I'm going
to take your knight and I'm going to
roll through with my pawns now it's
really forcing the issue and opening it
up where you have more space which in
the end is always going to be the idea
so with that you know I did promise to
take a quick look at the French to rush
so I just want to briefly introduce
another way of approaching these
positions which shows up sometimes so
it's the same pawn structure we see the
c5 this c3 a knight c6 92 takes takes
this is the French tirage and now you
know instead of trying to play on the
queenside
so much black actually ends up going for
a different idea so I I'm sure you guys
have seen it before
but what do you think it is yes you go
for this f6 move so previously we've
been playing where we've had more space
attacking the base of the pawn chain and
the idea here is to attack the head of
the pawn chain and again this ends up
going for a kind of a huge change of
structure after a takes F which is by
far the main move and Knight takes F and
again instead of one of these close
centers the center would become fluid
again and black would be trying to open
it up in the center and so the plans
here would be totally different which is
why I don't want to spend too much time
talking about it in an enclosed center
kind of lecture but it is worth
mentioning so any questions about either
game about the structure in general
about you know the plans and these these
positions alright with that in mind I
just want to briefly recap the idea and
closed positions like these are always
or usually play on the side where you
have more space look for pawn breaks to
open the position and you know play
every move with this purpose or with the
purpose of slowing down your opponent
those are the three big ideas I wanted
to get across today
with that in mind thank you guys for
hanging out Thank You YouTube viewers
for watching this has been the road to
mm be sure to join me next week
[Music]